this is a Fox News Alert the president's
about to speak to his supporters tonight
in Tupelo Mississippi we just got word
he is in the vehicle on the weights of
the rally it's his first public event
since the House voted on impeachment so
were certain he'll have something to say
about that
could a Tupelo of course as soon as that
begins good evening a walk go to Tucker
Carlson tonight it was just this past
spring believe it or not that vada where
work summed up the 2020 presidential
race this way quote like this is the
fight of our lives as Americans and as
humans end quote
you can probably tell I want to run he
told Vanity Fair at the time I think I'd
be good at it
he said well many of the national media
agreed they thought he'd be good at it
too turns out he wasn't a work quit the
presidential race today after thoroughly
humiliating himself and the Democratic
Party while bringing his political
obituary in just a minute but first time
as we just told you the president
scheduled to start speaking this hour
from Mississippi and we expect there
will be some news made during that event
but no matter what the president says or
doesn't say tonight many in our
managerial class will vehemently
disapprove
they despise Donald Trump on principle
they love everything about him from his
mannerisms to his NATO policy and
everything in between but underneath it
all what they really hate is the fact
that he's a nationalist and even worse
he admits it they have a word it sort of
became old-fashioned it's called a
nationalist and I say really we're not
supposed to use that word you know what
I am I'm a nationalist okay
ooh cross the line they're nationalists
you can't say that in Washington it's
racist they'll tell you that from their
rigidly segregated neighborhoods they've
got the same demographic mix that he did
in 1952 a cable news meanwhile the term
is basically banned it's considered a
vicious slur nationalists use that word
we're going to talk about that word
tonight it is a favorite of the
alt-right and is loaded with nativists
and racial undertones
he's weaponized race and nationalism and
dog whistles they're suggesting there's
some kind of dog whistle there it is it
is it applies it does provoke hate
activity what are you trying to say as
president United States that you're a
nationalist Americans know what that
means it's not even a dog whistle
anymore it's a bull horn got that a dog
whistle and in DC that's bad pretty much
everyone there is a cat person
apparently but what exactly is a
national list and why are the people who
run our nation so threatened by it and
by the way if they're not nationalists
themselves what exactly are they